I'm in New Zealand my biggest fear for
your Heights they have one of those
giant space needles and I was like I'm
gonna jump off that needle and my buddy
Heath who was showing me around I go he
come jump out of that Hill he was like
I'll go with it [ __ ] great so we go
down there I walk into the office and I
ask the woman I go what's the deal
she goes okay it's 700 feet straight up
16 second fall
and then it's over I was like
it's over
and she said the jump is over I go
that's what that's what you should say
you should say the jump is over
I just [ __ ] a little bit for no reason
you know what I mean
I said what's the deal I'd like to see
someone jump when is that going to
happen she said half hour do you want to
wait scared of heights people you know
what we're not doing standing next to
that [ __ ] needle for 30 minutes no
way because then I'm never gonna jump
right I
I with every intention of
never coming back
but the truth of the matter is the only
reason I didn't just flat out not go
back I didn't want to come up with the
reason not to jump because I felt like
that would make me a [ __ ] but if
somebody else came up with the idea I
could just go yeah you're probably right
I probably shouldn't jumped right
and who's gonna give me that idea my
wife
I call her on the phone I go ahead about
it she goes hey
she said you knew that needle I said I
am and before I could say anything else
she said hey please don't push out
and I said watch because I know you're
calling me so I'll give you a reason not
a job I'm not going to do that that's
she said I know you and I know the only
way you get disappointed in yourself and
this is true is when you don't try when
you feel like you quit and you hold on
to that [ __ ] for a long time she said I
don't want that to happen to you I don't
want you to hang on to this for months
so please just jump
and I told her I go babe thank you very
much it's cool to be married to somebody
who knows me so well so I appreciate you
looking out for me and she said I I
didn't tell you that for you
I said what she goes you know when you
hang on to it you know what you do talk
about it all the time
she goes I don't want to hear you for
the next three months I should have
jumped you know I did a job
she said so just jump
there you go and I hang up the phone and
guys here's how you know I'm scared
when when you see me super confident
extra bravado
I'm frightened that's how like that's
what my Alter Ego is for my fear this is
how scared I was this is how much
bravado I had when I hung up the phone I
turned to my friend he and I think I
said something like hey
let's go [ __ ] that needle in the ass
scared right oh it's full of Rubino I go
hey you want to [ __ ] hate you want to
book your night
and I hope I wasn't doing this
I go hey you won't [ __ ] jump with me
and he was like
no
I said why not he goes for 16 seconds
his body's gonna feel like it's done
right I said yeah he goes yeah that
sounds terrible
I don't want to do that he said but I'll
be sitting right there drinking a beer
smoking a joint waiting for you is it
okay so I start to walk under the needle
and here's what I decide
[ __ ] the Bravada what I decided in that
moment was bravado was me pretending to
be somebody else and in order for me to
conquer this fear I want to do it as me
so I'm just going to embrace the sphere
and see what happens you know and as
soon as I let go of the bravado one
thing I did learn about myself is when
I'm super scared guys my lower body
sweats a lot
a lot a lot like a lot a lot right and
so I was like this is really weird
feeling you know
but I but it actually felt good I felt a
lot like present I felt there and I was
like [ __ ] and nobody knows me in New
Zealand I'll be just some scared sweaty
American they're gonna [ __ ] love that
right so fine just Embrace this get up
there conquer this fear check this box
and let's move on to the next one no one
knows you here you should feel the most
comfortable and I just hand this dude my
ticket and he goes Josh Wolf
and I looked at him and I go
are you sure
and he said are you not sure
I said no I'm sure I said how do you
know me man he goes I was at the Comedy
Festival last night to you're the whole
reason I want you're my favorite comic I
actually told everybody here about you
they're gonna be so psyched to meet you
hold on a second
semicircle around
now here's something you guys need to
know about me when I'm out in public and
I'm nervous and I don't know what to do
with my hands I do this on my nipples
so there's like 50 pictures of me with
these people like hey hey
by the way side note side note probably
about three or four times a year I like
to go to the casinos take some mushrooms
and play the slots
and I'll tell you why dude it's just the
simulation
and not too long ago I was at the
Mohegan Sun which is a casino in
Connecticut and I was dude I was like 3
30 in the morning I was on mushrooms
when I'm on mushrooms I rub my nipples
too
but not because I'm nervous just because
it [ __ ] feels good
and so I was playing slots and I had
like a
[ __ ] it was [ __ ]
it's crazy you know and there's a dude
sitting next to me and I didn't notice
he was there and at one point he looked
at me and he goes hey and I go yeah
and he goes he goes you
you rub your nipples for good luck
I mean what am I gonna do saying no I
I so I said yeah
so me and this dude sat next to each
other
[ __ ] rub their nipples again
at one point he was like it's not
working I'm like you gotta rub him
harder he's like
okay
so
I think it'll make a little circle
around me and the people there know I'm
a comedian and they know I'm scared and
and they're making some jokes and I
don't mind that [ __ ] you know and the
guy standing next to me goes all right
everybody enough for the jokes Time to
Say Goodbye to Josh and I was like
goodbye and he was like it's just a
saying I go [ __ ] change it
and he puts me in my little one suit in
my onesie in my in my jumpsuit you know
and uh and he put a harness on me real
loose and then he puts me in this
elevator and he goes here you go
this elevator is going to take you 700
feet very slowly straight to the top
and the doors start to shut
and I go orange you get in he goes no
just you
[Laughter]
elevator slowly Rises out of the ground
and as it does I look around
now this elevator is like 80 glass
I don't like the window open on the
[ __ ] airplane
[Applause]
thank you
but 80 glass you know what that means
right
20 whoa
so I'm not kidding when it lifted out of
the ground I turned around and I [ __ ]
Blair witched myself right against the
wall I just sat like it
I put my face against the wall I closed
my eyes and I was like this is it right
here I'm just threading this right here
and guys I was like 75 sure I was gonna
die so I started talking to people in
the elevator who I wanted them to hear
from me one last time like I was talking
to my parents like Mom and Dad thank you
for always believing in me Beth you're
the best decision I ever made Jacob and
Caitlin and Trevor you're my three
heartbeats how do I know I was screaming
all those embarrassing things
well apparently they videotape you
you walk in the element oh a heads up
would have been nice a sign smile you're
on camera something you know what it is
it's just a video of me screaming the
bitchiest [ __ ] [ __ ] any human has ever
streamed
I was screaming things like guys I am on
tape screaming this if it's my time to
go I'm ready but I'm not ready
so we get to the top right I get to the
top and the door opens
and at the top for these two young
ladies
and one was this sarcastic
biting
say anything to your face
I don't give a [ __ ] about your feelings
kind of person
and the other woman was
exactly the same
and I get up there right
and they started laying into me
immediately the door opens and I just
hear one of them go
well come on out here princess
and I walk up to the desk
and she hands me a clipboard
and she goes here you go I go what's
this you know I need you to fill out
this waiver I was like right
I said what's this waiver for she said
you know what the waiver is for
I never had to use the waiver she said
no I said well that's good she said yeah
but their families did what
oh she was [ __ ] with me so hard I
appreciated it but it was scary you know
she goes head out there they're waiting
for you and I walk out on the deck no
has anyone in here ever been on top of
one of the needles the Strat in Vegas or
oh yeah did you did anyone jump no no
you jumped no
no there you go
and did you you Skydive you skydived
yeah
I will tell you first of all guys one
thing that and anybody who's been on top
of these needles will tell you from the
ground looking up from the middle to the
edge looks huge when you get up there
it's 15 feet Max and at the Strat just
like all these places there's a railing
that you would hold and you walk out to
the edge which is what I'm sure most
normal people do
not your boy I was so scared guys I'm 15
feet from the edge right when I get out
there I grab the railing with both hands
like this
squeezing it white knuckling it and I'm
doing this with my feet this feels safe
this is safe
let's feel safe this is safe this feels
safe how do I know I was saying that
oh they videotape that part too that's
right
[Laughter]
guys can I tell you something when I
finally get down to the ground the woman
who sold me the tickets she walks up to
me and she goes hey I go yeah she goes
you want that video
yeah I want the video
she was okay
I hope you got a lot of room on your
phone
and she goes what's the longest video
I've ever had to send anybody
how long is the average video she was
five and a half minutes I go well how
long was I up there she said 37 minutes
I said no way she goes yeah you did safe
safe for 17 minutes
were they watching in real time
how humiliated I'm up there [ __ ] good
day they're in the office like ah okay
thank you
and by the way guys
there are two groups that they let up on
that needle the jumping group the other
group
they will let you do two things they
will let you walk along the Edge by
yourself
they say that cures your fear of heights
no hey [ __ ] you that's right
you know what else they'll do dude you
ready for this
they'll attach a hook to your onesie
your jumpsuit and they will hang you off
the side so you're flat looking down yo
dude this guy won't tell me he was hey
you want me to hang out the side
and I was like do you want me to [ __ ] in
your mouth
well I will [ __ ] up I will beat gravity
are you
are you man read the room bro no I do
not want you to hang me off the side of
this needle I'm just trying to keep my
[ __ ] together right now you know what I
mean
so the mother of the woman who was in
charge of you know get me out there she
goes all right come on you got to jump
I've been up there for at least 17
minutes she was so sick of me at this
point in time she goes come on you gotta
jump over here there's a line of people
waiting to get up here come on
and I go well what happens if I don't
jump
she goes what do you mean I go what
happens if I get in that elevator I ride
it straight down
and just nobody ever knows
she goes well I mean if you did that
somebody might tweet about it
I said are you telling me that if I
don't jump off this needle you're going
to Tweet about it she goes no I wouldn't
I think Twitter's stupid I really think
it's really dumb I said thank you she
said of course but she would and her
friend was like
I said can you help me I'm just so
scared she is do you not will you let me
do my job
she said do you think you're the first
grown man I've had to talk off of this
needle
you're not she goes let me ask you a
couple questions if you Googled us I
said of course
she goes this is your biggest fear I
said it is she goes right she said when
you Googled us did you find anyone ever
died here I said no
she goes yeah has anyone ever been
injured here I said no
you said that's right you were quite
literally scared of nothing
you're making things up to be scared of
instead of making things up let me just
give you the facts we've been here
for years
thousands and thousands and thousands of
people jump off here every year and
nobody ever even gets hurt we change
lives she goes let me tell you something
right now when you jump off of here when
you hit the ground I go hit the ground
foreign
she said you got to be a new person
you're going to be a new person
I said
no
that's your pep talk new person is your
halftime speech I go that's not working
for me what else you got she goes okay I
was just throwing that one out and I got
a couple more she said you got kids I
said yeah she goes your kids know you're
here I said yeah she goes you want to
disappoint your kids I said I disappoint
my kids all the time what else
go fish that [ __ ] doesn't work on me
either
she said all right your kids know you're
scared I said of course
he said do you want your kids to know
that it's okay to quit in life when
they're scared
and I was like
I want to [ __ ] push you off here
I was like no I don't want that she said
of course you don't she said get up
there
I'm gonna get up to the edge
and I stand there guess what scared of
heights people it's not real until you
hear your very first
and my man that is followed quickly by
boom boom
and she
tightened up my harness Joy I'm not
gonna lie to you she squished my left
nut
and on a normal day I'd have told her to
loosen that up but looking 700 feet
straight down
I'll be all one Josh I don't give a [ __ ]
it's better than being all dead Josh
that's what I'll tell you what right now
and what a great story to tell your
grandkids hey how's your lose how'd you
lose your nut pop pop it exploded in
midair kids you know
so I'm standing there and something
happened to me that I'd only heard about
you guys heard the term Frozen with fear
I didn't think that was a real thing
until I couldn't move my [ __ ] body
and I just
had to tell her I said listen I want to
tell you something for real
no [ __ ] around I have to do this
today this is why I'm here
I cannot let my fear beat me today of
course I don't want to disappoint my
kids but the real reason I'm here
is she's right I grew up with a lot of
irrational fears and I promised myself I
would not hang those handles down to my
kids and the only way for me not to hand
this down is to do this today right now
I have to show them that there's nothing
to be scared of
but
I can't jump
I said
you're gonna have to push me
and she looked at me and she goes
I know
[Laughter]
I said you know she goes yeah we wash
your elevator right up I knew I was
gonna have to touch it
are they watching the [ __ ]
[Music]
thank you
it's like okay
but by the way scared ice people guess
what if they push you you have to go off
backwards
you have to see the push they can't push
you in the back it's against the law so
I turn around and she starts to walk at
me like this and I was like are you out
of your [ __ ] mind right now you think
I'm gonna let you push me like you're
one of the Walking Dead get your [ __ ]
together
yeah we're gonna have to plan this out
look man I grew up with three older
brothers man a lot of us who grew up the
youngest of a big family there's some
PTSD that's involved with that [ __ ]
one of my things is I was scared
multiple times every day so that means
if you scare me to this day I'm gonna
Jazz it
not only am I on a jazz hand it's going
to be followed by this noise
100 of the time 100 of the time right I
already have [ __ ] James Dave
to go with it you know what I mean
don't you surprise me off this [ __ ]
needle now get me a good push
I go one two three push you ready
because I'm ready I go you ready she
goes I'm ready
foreign
she was so sick of me being up there
guys if she was allowed to scream what
you [ __ ]
you know I could tell she was sick of me
when she pushed me she didn't look at me
guys when you checked the camera she
pushed me when she was already walking
back to the office
and in the camera after she pushed me
she gave me three of these just like
that
foreign
I have a 16 second video
so I get down to the bot
and uh the woman said the video joke
comes up and she goes hey hey CEO wants
to talk to you got a minute so yeah
and he comes up to me he goes hey man
Tim hey I'm Josh and he said first of
all
how great was that I was like pretty
[ __ ] terrible
he was like but you're gonna do it again
I go
and he goes are you glad you did it I
said I'm so glad I did it and please
thank your staff they were very patient
with me
and I and I was about to walk away he
goes hey I just want you to know me
everybody in the office
we really enjoyed your video all right
so
I'm home a month later and this
and my buddy from New Zealand he he
calls me and he goes hey man I go hey he
goes hey have you
have you been on that New Zealand joke
website
and I said no and he goes you should
and I said what am I looking for he goes
you're looking for a video
I go where is it he goes this right on
the front page
so I go to the front page and there's a
video that's
in the beginning of the video he's just
given all the Vital Information about
the 700 feet 16 second fall where it is
in downtown Auckland what you can see
when you're at the top all the Vital
Information
and at the very end he goes but most
importantly guys what you need to know
is here at New Zealand jump we've had
Zero fatalities
here at New Zealand jump we've had zero
injuries what you need to know is that
New Zealand job is 100 and then it just
cut to a video Amigo and say save
[Applause]
[Music]
that's how big our titties were they
made that noise through the air